da ist ein weg
meine eltern kommen aus frankreich
deshalb habe ich einen französischen
namen und das habe ich mir schon gedacht
sie sprechen akzentfrei deutsch
meine eltern kommen aus kleinen
hellersdorf deshalb heiße ich hänge ab
sie haben humor das sagen nicht viele
nun dann sehen viele nicht richtig hin
haben sie schon aus der speisekarte
gewählt ja wie denn ich komme ja nicht
zum leser deutsche essen muss sowieso im
das gleich so ein quatsch natürlich
anders
der mann hatte gestern das wiener
schnitzel mit kroketten und gemüse das
bestellte heute sicher wieder vielleicht
diesmal mit pumpt fried und die frau
marx tomatensuppe
dazu nehmen sie einen gemischten salat
mit hähnchenfleisch
ich hätte
die frau bestätigt was anderes sie
wollen wetten
ich will sagen wenn sie verlieren müssen
sich noch einmal mit mir treffen
einverstanden
hallo was darf ich ihnen bringen ich
nehme die schweine lieber mit sauerkraut
und kartoffelpüree bitte eine kleine
portion und ich nehme die wurstplatte
und ich habe nach appetit auf den
kleinen ziegenkäse als vorspeise noch
ein glas wasser bitte einmal die roulade
mit salzkartoffeln anbot